hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich möchte heute ein richtig leckeres
rezept machen es gibt eine kalte suppe
denn zurzeit ist es jetzt ziemlich heiß
bei uns in deutschland und ich möchte
einfach gar nichts kochen möchte lieber
etwas schnell zusammenrühren und vor
allem was leichtes auch essen und diese
suche heute die es nicht nur leicht und
lecker sondern auch ziemlich versuchen
muss ich sagen weil wir echt nur gesunde
zutaten mit drin haben und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
natürlich gibt es verschiedene rezepte
für kalte suppen apathisch f1 von meiner
freundin und das finde ich richtig
lecker deswegen muss ich euch jetzt auf
jeden fall zeigen an zutaten brauche ich
hier sechs päckchen c4 ich sage euch
gleich dazu was es ist 200 gramm saure
sahne
dann habe ich hier zwei gläser rote
beete und zwar ist es ein abtropfgewicht
mit 220 gramm und insgesamt 440 1 bis 2
zitronen dann noch ein bisschen was
frisches und zwar im schnitt laufwunder
terrasse ich habe hier etwas dill 2
gurken und ein bund frühlingszwiebeln
und hier habe ich schon zehn eier
abgekocht und jetzt hier noch im wasser
gestellt damit sie schnell abkühlen mit
seinem akku kühler darunter dann geht es
nämlich ziemlich schnell und kefir das
ist so eine
sonja summ milchprodukt und zwar ist es
ähnlich wie buttermilch deswegen habe
ich jetzt auch mal ein päckchen gelassen
damit ihr das auch findet und auch nach
kaufen könnt und da sind so spezielle
hefekultur drin als ok vier kulturen und
ich habe mir dann erst gedacht ob das
vielleicht kaputt weil das hier so
gewölbt ist aber sich nicht kaputt denn
ich habe dann gleich nachgelesen und
zwar kommt es dadurch zustande dass
durch diese hefe kulturen einfach
kohlensäure gebildet wird und deswegen
hat es hier eben diesen erhöhten decken
also müsst euch keine gedanken machen
das ganze geht jetzt eigentlich auch
relativ schnell ihr könnt es auch am
abend vorher schon zu bereiten denn die
suppe muss später richtig kalt sein und
vor allem noch ein bisschen den
kühlschrank durchziehen so was mache ich
jetzt zuerst ich mach zuerst die
päckchen auf und gibt es alles in ein
großes gefäß das ist auch ganz wichtig
dass wir da jetzt was richtig großes hat
zwei polen vielleicht hätte ich
natürlich gebe ich jetzt hier in einem
großen topf
und bevor ich das zweite paket dazu gäbe
gäbe ich noch die saure sahne mit rein
denn dann kann ich das erst mal glatt
rühren
und dann wird es einfach schön verrührt
bis sich die saure sahne mit dem tv
verbunden hat
jetzt geht hier einfach noch die
restlichen becher mit rein einfach alle
zusammen können dann natürlich auch
buttermilch neben falls sie jetzt kein
käse findet gps die mildere variante
buttermilch feierlich ein schneebesen
wird jetzt allerdings zu klein ist eine
richtig große portion also können locker
sechs personen dann damit essen oder
erst auf zwei tage verteilt
13 versuchen jetzt nehme ich mir noch
etwas mineralwasser also mit sprudel und
nehmen einen becher spülen damit aus
kommt mit allen habe auch keine
verschwendung habt ihr alles mit drin
und es gebe ich dann hier noch mit rein
das macht das ganze bisschen flüssiger
dann nehme ich jetzt die rote beete und
die kommt jetzt direkt mit der
flüssigkeit damit dazu sorgt natürlich
auch gleich für die tolle farbe also das
wird auch eine richtig schöne suppe und
ihr könnt jetzt entweder diese fotos
direkt aus dem glas nehmen die schon
direkt klein geschnitten ist oder was
ich hier auch habt das ist abgekocht
rote beete das ist auch wirklich nur
abgekocht und geschält das heißt da es
sonst nichts mit drin
hier schon noch so ein bisschen essig
mit dabei bisschen zucker aber das
müsste einfach selber entscheiden wenn
er es halt so nimmt müsste da auch ein
bisschen es sich mit run geben und etwas
zucker und das ganze dann erst mal eine
nacht ziehen lassen deswegen habe ich
das jetzt so ein glas direkt genommen
und dann könnte das jetzt erst mal auf
die seite stellen können natürlich auch
schon mal ein bisschen verrühren und als
nächstes nehme ich mir jetzt schon mal
die kurven und die werden jetzt auch
fein geraspelt ihr könnt auch würfeln
aber ich finde es viel schöner weil die
rote bete auch gastwirt und das mache
ich jetzt hier einmal in der kenwood
dafür halbiere ich jetzt einmal sonst
kann es sein dass wir oben nicht durch
passt durch diese öffnung
jetzt kommen die gurken auch direkt mit
rein
als nächstes nehme ich mir jetzt den
schnittlauch und das ganze gemüse als
auch die zwiebeln wird dann schön fein
geschnitten
ich schneide es jetzt im kleine päckchen
denn ich mache das jetzt einfach alles
im alligator drin könnt natürlich auch
einfach mal besser machen aber das geht
es immer schneller
dann kommen die zwiebel und die schnitte
würfelchen hier mit rein und als
nächstes werde ich auch direkt auf
eierschalen und die eben auf einköpfen
mein papa hat mir das beigebracht
und zwar habe ich sie natürlich jetzt
kalt abgeschreckt und kalt werden lassen
und dann einfach super klopfen dann so
kissel die haut lösen gibt nämlich
einfacher und dann können das hier
unterschiede seien bei frischen eiern
ist so da löst sich die schale nicht so
ganz gut
diesen jetzt glaube ich ein paar tage
alba geht sitzt und so geht's halt
schneller wenn man die kurze zwischen
den händen
habe ich die eier auch schön gewürfelt
und kann ich sagen zehn eier passend
alligator ein als echt kein problem habe
ich jetzt auch schon mal getestet
vor allem sind die würfel auch echt
schön also jetzt nicht erwartet da wird
es in echt super geworden hätte ich
jetzt mit messern herz so gut
hinbekommen so das geht jetzt hier auch
alles sein also viele denken ist
wahrscheinlich auch mein gott was wird
das für eine suppe hatte ich auch das
erste mal gedacht wie ich dann die super
gesehen habe fand ich sehr appetitlich
aber wie ich gehört habe was alles so
drin steckt habe ich auch gedacht aus
schmeckt es wirklich so gut aber sehr
schädlich sehr lecker also richtig gut
und ich sehe auch karate kendo schlüssel
ist groß genug für diese portion so den
brauche ich es nicht mehr
und hier habe ich jetzt bereits auch
schon mal den grill abgezockt und zwar
einfach die dünnen stengel hier
wegnehmen die dicken nehmer nicht und da
gibt jetzt einfach so viel rein wie ihr
möchtet also dass ich wirklich
geschmackssache
ich mag diese sehr gerne vor allem finde
ich sehr erfrischend deswegen nehme ich
jetzt hier den ganzen bund und wenn ihr
das nicht so gerne möglich nimmt ein
bisserl lebens und es schneide ich jetzt
einfach kurzem messer geht so ganz
schnell gut hätte ich jetzt auch im
alter machen können aber da habe ich
jetzt hier gemacht und ich glaube es
lebt man so wissel die dicken stengel
nämlich weg kommt es auch mit hier rein
und dann nehmen wir noch eine zitrone
die knete ich vorher immer durch den
dann kommt auch der saft schön raus da
oben nämlich auch auf den zipfel weg
als dann mit der cdu-sprecher leichter
geht und ich nehme ich erst mal den saft
von 1 zitrone und später kann ich dann
immer noch abschmecken ob ich noch mehr
soll betraut oder doch nicht
deswegen erstmal nur eine
unter dem eimer schönen durchführen
jetzt können wir es auch an dieser
stelle bereits mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
so habe ich jetzt erstmal pfeffer
nämlich immer gern frisch gemahlen weil
es besser schmeckt hatten viel besseres
aroma ich nehme doch nicht zu viel denn
ich las es ja noch mal im kühlschrank
durchziehen und dann kann man das immer
noch abschlag
und jetzt denke ich da noch lege ich
dann noch im deckel drauf ist auch
richtig gut weil solches ganze
geruchsneutral dann auch im kühlschrank
wir müssen uns ganz schön viel aromen
ich würde für euch auf jeden fall
empfehlen dann deckel drauf zu setzen
gibt es jetzt den kühlschrank für
mindestens drei bis vier stunden am
besten wirklich über nacht können dass
abends zu bereiten und dann am nächsten
tag essen und befeuchtet dann raushole
setze ich etwa so eine halbe stunde
vorher kartoffeln an und zwar kids davon
im kreis kartoffeln dazu aber das zeige
ich euch dann ganz einfach später
die suppe sich schön durch gezogen und
ich habe auch bereits meine kartoffeln
abgekocht und jetzt darf der morath
probieren wollte ich doch richtig toll
aber der papa markt ist richtig tolle
rosa
vielleicht ist es ja gesund
verrühren ich hör auf ich mag das nicht
dann kriegst du da noch die heiße
kartoffel mit dazu denn die gehört auf
jeden fall mit dazu aber ich lese jetzt
erstmal so hinstellen kannste dir selber
sieht aus wie sony brathering soll ja
vor allem ich glaub das war auch mal
sowieso ein arme-leute-essen also ich
kenne da auch noch eine andere variante
das heißt auch arme leute essen arme
leute essen
doch ich glaube es heißt so auf jeden
fall ist es immer so butter mädels mit
so ein paar zutaten aus dem
vorratsschrank rote beete im glas hat
man da oder halt kann man sich kaufen
auf vorrat und das andere sind ja ein
paar frische zutaten es ist ein sehr
günstiges rezept und mit den warmen
kartoffel natürlich auch sehr sättigend
und ich finde im sommer ist ideal weil
man halt was warmes irgendwie aber auch
als kaltes und es ist sättigend sehr
erfrischend muratow darf probieren wenn
du möchtest
ich probier jetzt muss es probieren
aber ich sehe ehrlich wer schafft es
macht der kurzen stücken schale
also mach es jetzt rüber ja nein du
musst doch jetzt die kartoffel
abgelaufen
und jetzt zuhören und dann verbrennt man
sich auch nichts mit dem und probieren
ich finde die farbe einfach nur klasse
also allein schon wegen der farbe findet
machen und ja es ist sättigend
ich bin schon dafür schmecken kann man
das jetzt auch am nächsten tag noch
essen
ich habe es also ihr könnt einen tag
vorher vorbereiten und ich finds echt
super tolles rezept für eine kalte suppe
murat ist es noch ein tablett er spricht
jetzt nichts mehr
ihr dürft das rezept gerne nachlesen auf
sallys ganz genau
und ja ich freue mich wenn das nachmacht
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch noch andere
variationsmöglichkeiten für so kalt
besuchen dann schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare rein und wir sehen uns ganz
einfach beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann tschüss zschau
auf
mama 4